[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH GORDON: Hey, everyone.
Today I'd like to
make a quick video
that I hope will be
concrete and useful for you.
It's about the
very first machine
learning library I ever tried.
And it's called Weka.
What's great is that Weka
comes with a GUI that
makes it easy to
visualize your data sets
and train and compare
different classifiers.
And this is a really
handy tool to have
while you're learning ML.
I'll give you a quick
walkthrough of how to use Weka,
from installation all the
way to running experiments,
and show you some
of what it can do.
I'll demo training models
on two different datasets.
First, we'll
predict if a patient
has diabetes based on attributes
like their glucose levels.
And next, we'll predict
if a congressperson
is a Democrat or
Republican based on how
they voted on different bills.
I'll also show you
how to evaluate
the results of these
experiments and how
to do things like
feature selection
to discover which
attributes are important.
OK, let's dive right in.
The first thing we'll do is
download and install Weka.
And what's neat is that
it comes as a nicely
packaged application you can
run on Mac, Windows, or Linux.
There's also a Java API.
Here, I'll download
and install Weka.
And now I'll start it up.
There are different interfaces,
and we'll use the Explorer.
There's a lot on this screen,
but don't worry about it.
You'll get a feel for how
this works in a moment.
The first thing to
do is open a dataset.
So we'll hit Open.
And now would be a good
time to download one.
You can find a bunch
of prepackaged datasets
on this page.
And we'll start with
the UCI repository.
It contains about 37 problems.
And when you download
it, you'll get a JAR.
Now, you might be
familiar with these
if you're a Java developer.
But if not, don't worry.
You can treat them as a ZIP.
Here I'll unzip it.
And now we can see a
directory of datasets.
Let's return to Weka and
open one of these up.
And we'll start with diabetes.
All right, what do we see here?
Let me walk you through it.
First, let's learn
about the dataset.
At the top, you
can see there are
768 examples, or instances, and
nine attributes, or features.
The best attribute to start
with is class, or the label we
want to predict.
And usually in Weka, that's the
last attribute in a dataset.
Clicking on that, we
can see a histogram.
The blue column
on the left shows
the number of people who
tested negative for diabetes.
And the red column
on the right shows
those who tested positive.
Now let's look at
the attributes we'll
use to predict if a
patient has the disease.
The descriptions here
are pretty short.
But we can open up
the dataset in Sublime
or your favorite text
editor to learn more about
what they mean, as well as
how the dataset was collected.
Now, Weka datasets
come in an ARF format.
And this is just a CSV with some
metadata included at the top.
Scrolling down a bit,
we can see a description
of the attributes.
And the first
tells us the number
of times a patient was
pregnant, and the second
tells us their plasma glucose.
For diabetes, I
imagine one of these
is more predictive
than the other.
Let's see if Weka can
tell us that, too.
Back in the GUI,
let's click on plasma.
And what's cool is you
can see a histogram of how
different values correlate to
the class we want to predict.
Recall that blue is negative,
and red is positive.
And right off the
bat, we can see
this is a useful attribute,
meaning that if plasma is low,
say below about 100, then
it's unlikely the patient has
diabetes.
Most of these values are blue,
whereas as the value increases,
it's increasingly likely that
a patient has the disease.
Now let's look at pregnancy.
And to me, this doesn't look
like a strong correlation.
There may be one here,
but it's less obvious.
Now here's where things
get really interesting.
I've so much to
show you, but I want
to jump in and
classify this data.
So let's head over
to the Classify tab.
There's a whole bunch
of built-in classifiers.
Let's start with
the decision tree.
And J48 is one type of
tree that does pruning.
We'll hit Start, and bam.
We're done.
We just trained a decision
tree on the diabetes dataset.
Let's say we also wanted to
train a linear classifier,
like logistic regression.
To do that, we can go
into Functions, Logistic,
and hit Start.
And there we go.
This is great,
because we can flip
back and forth between the
two and compare the results.
There are many types
of classifiers in Weka
if you're interested,
everything from naive
Bayes to basic neural networks.
Now let's head back to the
tree and see the results.
And there's a lot of
information on this screen,
so let me walk you through it.
Let's scroll to the
top and start there.
First, you can see
the trained tree.
As always, you read
it from the top down.
It's telling us to start by
looking at the value of plasma.
And this happens to be the
most predictive attribute
in the dataset, but we'll
return to that later.
Scrolling down, we can see
the accuracy was about 73%.
But what exactly was the
accuracy evaluated on?
Well, here you can see Weka
gives you three options.
The first would be to compute
the accuracy on the training
set.
And if we do that, of
course it will be higher.
It goes up to 84%, because
we've tested the tree
on data it's already seen.
Of course, this isn't
useful in the real world.
As always in machine
learning, our goal
is to generalize from
the training data.
Ideally, we want a
model that performs well
on data it's never seen before.
So how can we know if it does?
Well, one way to simulate that
is to have a separate test set.
Basically, you can divide
the diabetes ARF file
into two separate files, one for
training and one for testing.
Use the testing file
only rarely to see how
well your algorithm performs.
Another thing we can do
is use cross-validation.
And this sounds
fancy, but all it does
is iteratively divide the
dataset into two chunks.
The larger chunk is
used for training,
and the smaller one
is used for testing.
We train a model,
evaluate it, and repeat
this process a number of times,
then average the results.
And Weka automates
this process for you.
Now, let's look more
closely at the evaluation.
You'll see stats like these
for any classifier you train.
And importantly,
notice that there
are metrics like precision and
recall in addition to accuracy.
Why?
Well, although accuracy
is the first thing
we think of when
evaluating a classifier,
it doesn't always tell
us the whole story,
especially in datasets
where one class is rare.
For example, let me
show you how to write
a 99% accurate classifier
that doesn't really
do anything at all.
Imagine you're writing a program
to assist a doctor, like we're
doing with this
diabetes dataset.
Now imagine that the disease we
want to predict is very rare.
Say only one person
in 100 is sick.
So how can you train a
99% accurate classifier
without using any ML at all?
Well, it's simple.
It turns out you can
write one line of Python.
Def diagnose return healthy.
Because most people
are healthy, just
by predicting that everyone
is, or the majority class,
we're 99% accurate,
but not useful.
Our model will always be wrong
when the patient is sick.
That's why when we
evaluate classifiers,
we have to look at accuracy both
on the positive and negative
cases.
And there are different
ways to do this.
A confusion matrix like we see
below is one of my favorites.
And you can find a
link in the description
to learn more about it.
Now onto another topic.
Imagine we had asked the
question, which attributes
in the dataset are important?
Here we don't want
to train a model.
We just want to
explore the data.
There's a technique we can use
called feature selection which
can help.
And the first thing we can
do is rank the attributes
by their information gain.
Let's head back to the diabetes
dataset for an example.
We can hit Filters, Supervised,
Attribute, Attribute Selection,
then select Info Gain
as the method and Ranker
as the search.
And when we run
this, the attributes
will be sorted by how useful
they are to predict the label.
If you could know just one
feature from the dataset,
you'd probably want
to know plasma.
If you could know two
things, you'd probably
also want to know mass.
But keep in mind we
haven't done a search.
It's possible that these
two attributes are not
the best combination.
There are other
methods of selecting
attributes, like
this, if you want
to find the best subset to use.
An exhaustive search can be
computationally expensive,
though.
Now let's look briefly
at the vote data.
I'll move faster this time,
because training and evaluating
a classifier uses
the same pattern.
This dataset is from
the US Congress,
and the goal is to predict
if a representative is
a Democrat or a
Republican based on how
they voted on different bills.
As before, let's
start with class.
Here, blue are Democrats
and red are Republicans.
And this dataset was
collected back in the 1980s,
so these ratios are different
than they are today.
Each attribute describes
how a congressperson
voted on different bills.
And many are predictive.
If you flip through them,
you'll see that many votes
are divided along party lines.
As before, you can read details
about the bills in the ARF
if you're interested.
And if we train a tree,
these are the rules
you can use to predict
the political affiliation
of a member of Congress based
on their voting history.
It's still amazing to me how
easy this tool is to use.
And I find it helpful
on a regular basis.
I usually begin my experiments
with a decision tree
to learn more about the
data and as a sanity check
for a baseline
classifier before I
move on to more complex
models like neural nets.
OK.
I hope this was helpful and
that Weka makes it easier
for you to learn ML.
Thanks, everyone, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]